on a les ingrédients en quelque sorte
d'une justice à l'américaine des
montants mirobolants et des caméras qui
en direct ou de ce procès un objet
médiatique autant qu'un objet judiciaire
hurd je pense qu'elle a très bien
compris la situation dans laquelle elle
et je pense qu'elle sait que l'opinion
publique ne lui est pas forcément
favorable
[Musique]
soit
soumis tout
comme paul stanley for you pay for you
aux
indes
maîtrise
ès quoi elle expose
secteur judiciaire en plus comme ils
sont acteurs dans la vraie vie joue
autant pour le jury que pour les
téléspectateurs et les réseaux sociaux
jouent en direct le procès parallèlement
à ce qui se joue précisément en virginie
dans la salle d'audience devant le jury
puisque c'est un jury populaire et ça
aussi son impact sur les registres
d'argumentation qui vont être utilisés
le fait que le procès soit filmé et
offre une caisse de résonance qui lui
permet aussi de
s'exonérer médiatiquement s'il ne
parvient pas à le faire judiciairement
il a fait preuve très tôt d'une certaine
vulnérabilité devant le tribunal il se
présente lui ce sont ses mots comme une
victime de violences conjugales très
apprécié du grand public très populaire
et en même temps assez décontracté assez
drôle il essaie un peu de tourner en
dérision les accusations qui sont
portées contre lui il rit beaucoup il
joue en quelque sorte sur joue peut-être
on le verra à la fin la sincérité de son
propos dire moi je vous parle avec mon
coeur est donc avec les hésitations peu
celui ci comporte ce qui frappe
évidemment c'est le contraste d'attitude
entre eux johnny depp et amber il
s'arrête à chaque fois qu'un mot est
important qu'ils cherchent ce mot et que
comme chaque mot doit être pesé au
trébuchet
eh bien il va faire un silence pour
chercher les mots importants vers eux
mme
c'est un mot important juridiquement
c'est une sorte de qualification donc il
va chercher le mot argument qui ne veut
rien dire qui sera laissé au hasard ou à
l'improvisation
et somme
[Musique]
eelv a avoué avoir tué trop violent il
va avouer avoir pu être ivre ce qui est
une façon de se donner en termes de
rhétorique on appelle ça les tos c'est à
dire l'image que l'on veut donner de soi
c'est je vais donner en concédant un
certain nombre de faits sur des ivresses
passé en concédant cela je m'érige comme
ayant tu l'ethos de l'honnêteté de la
vérité de sorte que lorsque je conteste
les faits qui me sont reprochés par en
bloc et bien g7 mais l'image de
sincérité dans cette sincérité est en
quelque sorte transposable il est
frappant aussi chez johnny depp c'est le
regard johnny depp ne regarde pas le
jury regarde un peu dans le vide or elle
regarde le jury salue a été d'ailleurs
reproché au lieu de repos regardez son
avocat elle dépeint johnny depp comme un
monstre c'est un récit auquel elle se
tient depuis le début du procès le 11
avril est là pour le coup une une
attitude beaucoup moins décontracté je
pense qu'elle sait que l'opinion
publique ne lui est pas forcément
favorable
on perçoit un certain changement
d'attitude de johnny depp qui lui garde
la tête baissée évite le regardant bird
et plus tôt soit en train de s'adresser
à ses avocats soient en train de faire
des petits signes de tête de dénégations
il est quand même dans une attitude un
peu plus sérieuse qu'il ne l'était au
départ durant ce procès on a quelqu'un
qui parle beaucoup plus vite qui a le
regard porté vers le jury et qui non
seulement raconte la scène mais la vie
est ouest
ap
ses détracteurs l'ont l'ont accusée sur
jouez également la scène et de confondre
en quelque sorte le prétoire avec un
rôle et chacun en effet joue un rôle
extrêmement émotionnelles mais
n'oublions pas également que pourquoi
est-ce que l'émotion et en devant de la
scène parce que qu'ils jugent non pas
une juridiction de professionnels mais
un jury populaire et donc ils sont aussi
attachés à faire passer à ce jury qui
est donc une série d' américains tirés
au sort à faire passer à ce jury
populaire des émotions que le chili peut
lui même ressentir donc on n'est pas
dans une juriste ou juridiction
professionnelle qui pourrait être plus
rationnelle si on joue sur l'émotion
c'est qu'un jury va juger
[Musique]
donc voilà on a une justice à
l'américaine qui pour nous provoque une
certaine stupéfaction mais après tout
puisque désormais il est possible en
france deux fils mais également les
procès de façon plus restrictive que ce
n'est pas aux états unis on a peut être
la préfiguration de ce qui se fera un
jour chez lui
[Musique]
à